uh another question popped up in my mind
because somebody asked me and I didn't
had the question which is not related to
the current topics
so uh in the Bible what is the marital
age for a female and a male she has to
reach past puberty she must be post
pubescent meaning not that she's
pubescent past that age and she's fully
mature psychologically and physically
that she understands what sexual
intimacy is about and her body is mature
enough to handle it that's the principle
comes from passages such as 1
Corinthians
736 now because you're reading the new
Indian version It's Not Gonna help you 1
Corinthians
7:36
7:36 you guys want to a little more
deeper on why when there's a blood it's
not just the woman if a man is bleeding
you're not supposed to get near
him or if he has a discharge you're not
supposed to you know he's got to now
sanitize himself you guys want me to go
deep on
that yeah you would be Kendrick that's
where you're like man I wish I was
married sucks being you buddy we all
wish we were married well those of us
who are single anyway 1 Corinthians 7:36
if anyone if anyone is worried that he
might not be acting honorably towards
the Virgin he is engaged to and if his
passion are too strong and he feels he
ought to marry he should do as he wants
he's not sinning see this is why you
really need to give up new Indian
version because even in the footnote you
see it says or the Greek can mean if
she's getting beyond the usual age for
marriage ah okay so version which one do
you want well I wrote an article on this
I'm G to give it to you again so I
forgot about the article okay but open
up the new King James version because I
want to now comment on how deep the
Bible is because everything that's
physical points a greater spiritual real
reality right but if a man thinks he is
behaving improperly towards his virgin
if she is past the flower of Youth
past she's fully
blossomed that means she's post
pubescent she's gone beyond puberty
here's my article in fact open up my
article perfect let me just do that I
give you the Greek words the lexans to
prove it watch here here the article
guys save
it okay now I quote it right and I give
you hi
hios that's the word now let's see what
it means here it is past the bloom of
Youth past her youth scroll down beyond
the amme or Bloom of Life past
prime overripe plump and ripe of a
virgin past the flower of her age
hm you get it yes and in my article I
give you I give you a host of
translations and commentaries that show
I'm not making this
up yeah the beauty right now is we can
just go to Bible Interlinear and we can
have all of these things right there so
if look give you another one are you
ready yes yes sir yes sir I am now guys
here's another one now in that article
of mine if you scroll up you'll see I
link to the original article go
up go up all the way guys save these
articles for your benefit you see it
says the following paper click on it
this is an even older paper when you
click on it before the Rapture oh wow no
no it's this is an even older paper I
use Ezekiel 16 versus 1 to8 now let me
break down Ezekiel 16 go there I'll give
you get to Ezekiel 16 you'll see
it uh not do because you know right
there that's Ezekiel 161 to8 now here I
quote 4 to 14 but read one to8 this is a
parable let me explain the parable okay
you ready I hope you guys are learning
I'm gonna have to retitle this excellent
questions you're blessing you came with
these questions I pray in Jesus name I
made no mistakes and he corrects me on
the spot May the Holy Spirit be
glorified in and through us okay
now God is gonna liken his relationship
to Israel as a man marrying a woman he's
giving a parable now remember how
Parables
work God will use Parables that are
based on everyday activities things that
we normally do like a sewer went and
planted seed right a man bought a field
so the parables are based on actual life
experiences right yes sir so now he's
going to give a parable of a man
marrying a woman now as we do that let
me see if the cat wants again he talks
about an infant girl being abandoned in
the desert to die this assumes
right that just like Muslims claim at
the time Muhammad there are people who
are embarrassed by having girls and they
would throw them in the desert to die so
then God Likens himself listen to how
beautiful God is as a man who found this
infant
girl Israel in the desert okay in the
desert and then he says to her live live
you'll see it right there on the day you
were born your cord was not cut nor were
you washed with water to make you clean
nor were you rubb with salt or wrapped
in cloths no one looked on you with pity
or had compassion enough to do any of
these things for you rather you were
thrown out into the open field faside
killer for on the day you were born you
were despised then I passed by and saw
you kicking about in your blood and as
you lay there in your blood I said to
you live so he saved her from dying I
made you gr like a plant of the field
now watch
watch well Minute Man contact me Skype
to see if you're kosher Mormonism is not
true it's of the devil now watch when
she was ready to be married because he
marries her you grow up you grew up and
developed and became the most beautiful
Jew Jewels your breasts were formed and
your hair grew that's talking about
pubic hairs now you became a woman your
breast form meaning you were mature and
you had pubic haes you were now
blossomed you who are naked and be later
I passed by see after you reach
puberty pass that point then I said
you're ready for love and he married
her wow
wow crazy crazy you know by the way let
me just tell everyone even if you look
on the Google and say marital age in the
Bible I have read maybe 10 different
articles
none of them give this kind of an
explanation except that they say in the
Bible there is no marital age they say
Bible doesn't describe that they say
some says puberty yes some of them do
they say that so Google does not have
this kind of an information in an
article let me just tell you that
because I did that I did that myself
before asking this question to sim now
go to the Bible commentary so you know I
didn't make it a minute man contact me
on Skype guys we're going to retitle
this I'll do mat Leck tomorrow God
willing these are too I'm sorry brother
I'm so sorry no these are too good man
no these are I'm not go to the section
on Bible commentary so you see I'm not
making it up you're going to go down
you're G to see it's going to get there
so there's the article you guys can see
it that's translations go down say full
maidenhood said okay here now watch Life
Application Study Bible this message
reminded Jerusalem of its former
despised status among the kenite Nations
using the imagery of a young baby
growing to mature
Womanhood see I'm not making it up
here's another one this comes from the
new interpreter Study Bible which is a
very liberal commentary the Lord passes
by twice the Lord's action contrasts
with that of the parents following
ancient near Eastern custom it's custom
of the time the Lord in Acts a legal
adoption by announcing literally in your
blood live the lifegiving act however
threatened by the nakedness of post
pubescent reality meaning she Beyond
puberty post Pua means Beyond puberty so
she had now gone beyond puberty and it's
there the Lord asks to protect the only
young woman who's now sexually mature so
when does he marry her when she's
sexually
mature you read another commentary lesle
C Allen word biblical commentary the
creative command turned into fact and
the baby grew into adolescence and
sexual
maturity marked by breast and pubic ha
see that
it's been there in front of our eyes but
we need to seek the Holy Spirit and ask
the Holy Spirit to illuminate us because
I didn't learn this from people I was
just reading Ezekiel 61 day and boom it
downed on me glory to the Holy Spirit
here another
commentary right Lamar Eugene coper
senior new American commentary an
exegetical and Theological exposition of
Holy scripture God then cared for the
nation and caus it to increase and
flourish like sprouts in a field
language reminiscent of the growth of
the nation in Egypt as described in
Exodus 17:12 so she Israel prospered
until she reached the maturity of
Womanhood she was a woman now as a
beautiful young woman of marriageable
marriageable age she became the wife of
Yahweh you catch it in yes sir here it
is another one the word of the Lord was
all it took to turn the field into from
a place of death to a place of Life
subsequently she grew up and reached
sexual maturity and attained an age
appropriate for marriage you became the
most beautiful Jewels your breasts were
formed and your hair grew should perhaps
be translated you develop the ornament
of ornaments namely your breast were
formed and your pubic care sprouted the
point is the physical development that
accompanies the onset of
puberty I mean we can go on right yeah
so many you have placed there now this
is beautiful so so by this lot by these
two verses alone
uh 7:36 of first and go to the last one
which is uh non-Christian can you scroll
down to the last one and then you can
ask your question because this one I
want you to look at watch here right
there a non-Christian Jewish commentary
this is a Jewish commentary a liberal
one the Jewish Study Bible look what
they say God Wills the abandoned infant
to live she lives and grows to puberty
upon reaching puberty she's ready for
marriage there you go but go ahead ask
your question now no so basically when
Muhammad married Aisha even if she is
pesent now
she is not ready for marriage no she's
not puent but even if she even if she no
she has to be post like 1 Corinthians
7:36 Beyond being riped ex meaning she
has to be psychologically mature and
physically this is why even Mary what
you want to say she's 15 she was
psychologically mature because when
she's told she's going to give birth to
a son Luke 134 she goes how can this be
I haven't had sex so she knows how
children are produced mhm you think an
8-year-old nine-year-old knows that not
at all you think my 11y old knows
that not at all no she doesn't she
doesn't not at all not at all not even
my 13-year-old knows that not yet and I
pray they don't please Lord Jesus
protect them oh